>> Tucker: I WANT TO END ON A
STRONG NOTE AND BY STRONG
RIPPLING STEROID ENHANCED
HEAVILY BICEPS, CHEAP
BODY BUILDING CORRESPONDENT
SPENT HIS SUNDAYS ON MOST
WEEKENDS HANGING BUT STRANGERS
ON SOCIAL MEDIA EXCHANGING WITH
THE FASTEST PROPORTIONALLY
MENTALLY ILL DIGITAL ONLINE, A
GROUP FOR CHRIS WHO OMO AND
ANOTHER JOURNALIST FILLS THE
VOID FOR ACTUAL LOVED ONE SHOULD
BE.
WHO ALMOST WAS TALKING ABOUT
HIMSELF WHEN A FELLOW TWITTER
USER ESSENTIALLY TOLD HIM TO
BE QUIET, YOU WILL BREAK YOUR
ARM IF YOU KEEP THE CRIME FOR
WHICH GOD SPOKE DOWN, OWN IT.
WE WON'T REPEAT IT.
HOW DID CHRIS CUOMO RESPOND TO
THIS?
HE DIDN'T SEEM EMBARRASSED.
HE WASN'T.
INSTEAD, HE SENT ME A PICTURE OF
THAT VERY ARM.
HOW THIS HAPPENED, CUOMO WROTE,
"DON'T HATE, FACILITATE."
TO FACILITATE?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN.
WE ARE NOT SURE BUT IT SOUNDS
LIKE A PICKUP POINT.
WHEN CHRIS CUOMO ASKED HER TO
FACILITATE